consternation aux états unis il faut
dire même partout dans le monde grande
inquiétude aussi le président américain
est devenu le patient le plus célèbre de
la planète il annoncé hier soir sur
twitter où cette nuit en fait que lui sa
femme avait contracté la coved 19 et
tout à l'heure il a été transféré à
l'hôpital walter reed dans la banlieue
de washington sous observation médicale
du tome on est quand même à un mois de
l'élection de m 3 octobre élection le 3
novembre
comment cette histoire va bouleverser la
campagne électorale
en fait tout est incertain maintenant
alors aucun américain se soit carrément
notre ami professeur en sciences
politiques à l'inversé le charbon soit
karine et sonia dridi de washington
collaboratrice et auteur du livre joe
biden le pari de l'amérique en petite
robe
bonsoir madame claudie bienvenue avec un
soir tout commence avec vous car in on
entend parler de l'expression la
surprise d'octobre comme on se parle ou
toutes les semaines de semaine en
semaine on ne cesse de se dire qu'il ya
toujours quelque chose d'inattendu
quelle a été votre réaction vraiment
quand vous avez appris cette nouvelle
ou finalement quand même dramatique même
si il s'en sort bien ça reste dramatique
et les risques sont grands les eaux peut
être banalisé mais vraiment pour de
parler je le rappelle pour nos
téléspectateurs des questions médicales
en début d'émission avec karl weiss 1
les italiens mais en fait les pensées se
sont bousculés dans ma tête évidemment
parce que effectivement si jamais ça
devait dégénérer si jamais il devait y
avoir un problème médical plus plus
grave le président devait être dans
l'incapacité d'exercer ses fonctions
mais l'eau ça ça peut avoir des
significations assez particulière parce
que
mike pence deviendrait à ce moment là la
personne qui prendrait les décisions et
un mois d'élections
on se retrouverait avec un candidat qui
peut-être n'est pas en mesure d'être élu
alors tous assez bousculé dans ma tête
mais pour être parfaitement honnête j'ai
aussi pensé que même si les symptômes
sont tout à fait réelle je ne remet pas
du tout en cause
il ya aussi une opportunité médiatique
porte sommes donc ça lui va lui donner
beaucoup beaucoup de visibilité
médiatique dans les prochains jours
d'autant plus qu'elle joue byden annoncé
qu'il ne cesserait ses publicités
négatives contre autre chose donc c'est
une façon on le sait tous que fait
chausser pour détourner l'attention donc
que ça s'est pas bien passé pourvu cette
semaine donc ça peut être à la fois
l'avantagé au désavantage du divin c'est
tout ça qui a tourné en boucle je vous
dirais ces dernières heures dans mr donc
ce n'est qu'il est là qu vide et que ce
soit plus est grave
vous y ajoutez une petite mise en scène
ni s'il fait toujours un peu de
spectacle avec chop alors c'est pas
assez pas et il eu un seul but d'écart
mais oui parce que c'est quand même
inhabituel de se rendre par hélicoptère
à l'hôpital si on a des symptômes légers
alors que tout ce qu'il faut à la maison
blanche y compris la médicale pour être
traités sur place donc c'est cet aspect
inhabituel aulaqi qui est dit que
peut-être une petite mise en scène et on
l'a vu partir sur pied peut-être pas aux
mains de fer que d'habitude sur l'inde
rudy donc votre réaction à vous alors je
pense que c'est quand même un coup dur
pour la campagne de donald trump
c'est embarrassant et cela donne déjà un
avantage à dubaï donne qui a été très
qui a plus beaucoup de précaution
pendant tous ces derniers mois qui
portait toujours masse donald trump ces
mots qu'elle lui est là donald trump est
quand même décrédibiliser parce que même
au dernier débat présidentiel il s'est
moqué de joe biden quitte il porte le
mas même si la soixante mais soixante
mètres d'une personne et l'a8 se
retrouvent et bien testée positive par
duco bid et joe biden a été testées
négatives en plus au départ
donald trump ensemble ils semblent a été
un peu forcé 1,2 de faire cette annonce
parce que tout d'abord c'est une
journaliste de bloomberg qui a dit
qu'une collaboratrice de donald trump
avait été testé positif au co vie de la
maison blanche ne l'avait pas ne l'avait
pas annoncé et donc je pense que la
maison blanche s'était très vite obligé
de finalement annoncé que donald trump
aussi avait pris à avait passé un test à
suite à la faute est positif de cette
collaboratrice donc je pense que ça a
été quand même une idée des moments
assez compliqué à la maison blanche
donald trump qui adore faire c'est
meeting électoral qui adore être auprès
des électeurs a dû aujourd'hui à annuler
un meeting en floride et la floride
c'est aller tacler les sondages sont
plutôt serré entre jobs ait donné et
donald trump dans cet état même si joe
biden est en tête et donc c'est quand
même un coup dur alors après je pense
qu'en effet si ce sont vraiment des
symptômes légers parce que pour
l'instant d'aller aussi a eu c'est la
communication de la maison blanche ans
dépassera pas dire en chair dans les
maps sur et voilà il n'ya pas de
transparence assuré si jamais il s'en
sort bien alors là c'est sur l'île ce
sera un argument de campagne pour dire
que voilà finalement il convient de s'en
est bien sorti pas parce que karen
prémont l'estampé langer de la cour
suprême qui avait pris le dessus de la
campagne depuis samedi dernier le fait
que président soit déjà atteintes de la
commune et c'est que son épouse et
peut-être d'autres membres de son
entourage comme le vus se déplacer sans
masque mais bien dans le jardin le rose
garden le jardin des roses à ce beau
samedi dernier tout le monde s'embrasse
est serré la main peut-être pas avec
trop de l'entourage l'exécutif et tout
ça est ce que le message est ce que ça
va de tra lisez le message de monsieur
bail de nous ça va permettre aux
démocrates de mettre en valeur la
négligence dont a fait preuve monsieur
chrome depuis des mois et le fait qu'ils
n'aient pas suivi la science comme il
aurait pu mais je pense que oui ça va
devenir un argument extrêmement
important le désavantage de fait que le
président est soit un la copie 19 c'est
que ça ramène la pandémie à l'avant
scène alors qu'il avait tout fait pour
la mettre un peu sous le tapis alors là
est justement avec cette journaliste qui
annonce que quelqu'un dans la peur de
chanter et taper là on peut pas cacher
la chose et c'est pour ça justement de
cette mise en règle disputait à
détourner un petit sommet mais
effectivement savoir ramener le
l'importance de la pandémie et la
mauvaise gestion de chambre la pandémie
à l'avancé et c'est un avantage pour joe
biden il le dit lui qu'il continuerait à
faire campagne et en moins mais il a
quand même adressé ses voeux de prompt
rétablissement au mont bleu
présidentielle mais mais c'est clair que
l'heure est un argument de poids pour
les gens qui sont en faveur de mesures
peut-être plus draconiens bon cette fois
ci pourra faire ce fameux débat le 15
octobre non plus sonia dridi les alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour faire
passer son message
oui tout à fait alors il est en 40 et
donc le débat essentiel 15 octobre
beaucoup doutent que cela puisse être
possible et puis est ce que joe biden
draps se retrouver dans la même salle
que donald trump qui a été testé positif
aux coville en tout cas zhu weilin
clairement prend l'avantagé puis aussi
il a une stratégie plutôt intelligente
je pense parce que il n'a pas attaqué
indirectement le président depuis cette
annonce on compterait il a même dit que
son équipe de campagne allait suspendre
toutes les spots de publicité négatif à
destination de donald trump de joe biden
tente depuis le début on peut se poser
comme le candidat de compromis entre
républicains et démocrates comme une
personne qui vont unifier réconcilier la
nation et donc là il a une occasion en
or de montrer de se poser en fait que
comme comme un album à la stature
présidentielle de ne pas attaquer
directement le président et je pense que
c'est la situation est très ironique
mais la joe biden
vraiment de quoi prendre l'aventage est
ce que vous croyez karine que ça va lui
apporter davantage de sympathies de
l'électorat ou simplement envoyer le
message que ça confirme qu'il était
négligente donc on peut pas lui faire
confiance donc on se range du côté
démocrate sur quel côté ça va jouer
d'après vous le plus mais il faut pas
oublier à quel point la société
américaine n'allait pas la risée à
l'heure actuelle alors c'est très
difficile pour quelqu'un de changer de
camp comme ça on l'a vu depuis le début
de la campagne on n'en parle presque à
chaque semaine parce que j'ai toujours
des événements effectivement avec plein
de rebondissements et à chaque fois je
dis la même chose ça m'étonnerait que ça
change quoi que ce soit donc encore une
fois cette fois ci ça m'étonnerait que
ça change quoi que ce soit sauf
peut-être comme je le disais de ramener
le sujet de la pandémie à l'avant scène
mais si charm devait finalement s'en
sortir sans trop de dommage mais ça va
être facile pour moi de dire de voiliers
oriella finalement faut pas trop
s'inquiéter avec ça mais moi que 74 ans
finalement les pas de souci alors tout
se défaire de la façon dont ça va jouer
dans les prochains jours c'est pour ça
que cette fin de semaine en fait là
vraiment toute l'attention va être porté
sur dans notre chambre à l'hôpital mais
pas en même temps l'autre chose c'est
que les gens commencent à voter je suis
tout petit musée
quand je partage en vaut deux le vote a
commencé ils discréditent déjà le
processus électoral pourrait-on imaginer
que cette situation s'aggravait il
veille complètement faire annuler tout
ça ça se passe et de karine non c'est
pas passé de ces congrès qui a la
pouvoir de reporter l'élection